Jaquan starts off this hour in
washington d.c Hedrick wand how are you
okay
good how can I help today uh I just
first want to say thanks for taking my
call and giving me in a feminist
opportunity sure
so when basically calling today is to
get guidance from you because my wife
and I aren't seeing eye-to-eye on how to
move forward financially essentially has
to do with whether to move out of our
current place or not and whether to
purchase a new car or not currently we
live in a one-bedroom high-rise condo
with two children our only debt payments
we have right now currently are on our
condo and a piece of land that we own in
area each property is underwater I'm the
only one working right now my wife is at
home with the kids the current car we
have is a coupe the two-door on the
court and in order to get to the point
where we don't have any more debts in
just our properties we basically kind of
zeroed our contributions of TSP and we
don't have any other investments we
don't we're not putting towards any
other investments right what is your
income right now I'm at a 106 K and how
old are your kids at two years and two
months old so two years ago you had a
child and your only car was a coupe yes
for two years you've not that you've not
done anything about that and 22 years
ago you were living in a one-bedroom
condo and yes we've been in a kind of
for ten years now no but I mean the
families this family problem with the
one-bedroom condo being scrunchy and the
car being scrunchy has been going on for
at least two years plus about two years
almost three years because you knew a
baby was on the way and you knew this
was going to get tight yes sir so how
have you put up with it all this time uh
well we've kind of just been
I don't know we've managed we've just
made room and in the kind of that we
have shuffled things around got rid of a
lot of thing what is the condo worth
right now it's worth about 260 life I
would say and what do y'all want we owe
to 85 also you're pretty close okay and
is the underwater due to just the shift
in the economy or was it due to
something particular to that condo
project or area I think generally this
carry that we live in holds have been
holding its value well and I think it's
generally just because of the economy
okay so it's recovering then pretty
quickly you're starting to see it
probably dropped further than this and
you've already recovered a lot of your
value right yes so how long do you think
before it's right side up it's hard to
tell get maybe five years oh no no way
I mean it's come back a whole lot in the
last 18 months well I I guess that's why
I yield to you I don't I would that was
my guess I would say to get our full
value back because originally no not
full value I said the right-side up you
owe 285 you know only 20,000 bucks off
yeah yeah yeah I mean a year from now it
very likely would be up yeah that's
that's true okay
so here's what I would do um if what's
your car worth
maybe 2008 if you wanted to trade two
thousand dollar car for a two thousand
dollar car or if you just scratch up a
little cat bit of cash into a three
thousand dollar car
that's a four-door over a little cheap
minivan to get around and haul a couple
of kids easier than a coupe that's fine
with me I'm not going to tell you to go
into debt to buy a car because you got
kids these kids weren't a shock they're
not it's not something you didn't see
coming you knew they were here for two
years three years almost you've been
messing around with this so you could
tell it was there now but if you want to
trade cars around a little bit and just
make life a little bit more comfortable
that's fine I would sit down if I were
in your shoes and say by this date if
the condo is not right-side up we are
going to move out and rent
something and put the condo up for rent
until the value recovers okay so you can
have a little bit of better situation
with your family and I don't know what
this date is it's wherever you all run
out of the emotional energy to have two
kids in a high-rise condo one-bedroom
high-rise condo so if it were me it
would probably sound something like this
time next year if if it hasn't recovered
enough to put it on the market a year
from January we're going to try to stay
here one more year and if it hasn't by
then if we can't get on the market and
get it right side up and get out of it
then we're going to rent it and go rent
something that's got a couple of
bedrooms and is a little bit more
tenable for children and in the meantime
if you want to you know pay cash for the
change in a car that's fine I'm not
going to finance anything and I wouldn't
go by $15,000 car in this situation
because I know you don't have that kind
of money laying around or you would have
told me uh for a $15,000 car yeah cash
yeah we could oh you have cash laying
around we do actually have laying around
about 25 in just the bank okay well why
haven't you bought a better car because
the subtleties as I said before is the
land we have another piece of property
which is the land that's currently we're
trying to get that off of us we're
trying to go through a short sale with
that it's the short sell right now that
what the offer is is about thirty
thousand that's about the value of that
land right now and we're trying to keep
this cash available in case we have to
pay a large lump sum to the bank to get
out from under it why would you not buy
payments instead of a large lump sum and
wait on the value of the land to recover
well we are making three we're still
making payment now but that's a lot less
than thirty thousand bucks how much do
you owe on the land a hundred and twenty
and what is it on the market for 40,000
40,000 yes what happened that's is is
the area that the land is in
and I suppose these banks the banks
aren't offering loans anymore for land
so people are having to come full out
either with cash or a significant amount
of cash to be able to put down on a
piece of land so on that supposition
what your what your theory is is that
all land in America has dropped 80
percent in value and that's absolutely
ludicrous
no no that's that I wasn't saying that
at all because in Tennessee is no
different than Washington DC Dallas is
no different than Washington DC the
loans are still exactly the same the
loans for dry land for all and have
dried up somewhat it's very difficult to
get a loan I agree with you on that but
that's not what caused this value to
drop this far well then that's the only
thing that I thought of and so there's
something structurally wrong with that
particular neighborhood if that's all
that car all that land is actually worth
if I'm in your shoes I'm going to go buy
about a $5,000 car that will carry my
kids around and pay cash for the
difference in that and the car you're
driving and I'm going to wait one year
to put my condo on the market or put it
up for rent one of the two and try to
make it one more year before we do that
and continue to try to work your way out
of this land those are the three steps I
would do in your situation thanks for
the call
you